there's someone on the way some see if
William Shatner were in these movies how
interesting that would be star trek into
darkness is the sequel to the immensely
successful and popular 2009 reboot of
the Star Trek films directed by JJ
Abrams stars Chris Pine Zachary Quinto
Karl Urban and Benedict Cumberbatch yes
got zoe saldana in there Anton Yelchin
Simon Pegg great cast in this film star
trek into darkness as a film that's
about a terrorist this terrorist is out
there wreaking havoc Kirk Spock and the
whole crew are sent out to try to find
this guy and one of the best
rollercoaster rides I have seen in a
very long time ensues star trek into
darkness was freakin fantastic I love
this movie this is summer fun at its
best
I recently did my review for fast in the
Furious 6 now that was a really well
made fun action fest didn't have a lot
of substance though but I recognize that
film for what it was a really fun movie
that I hope you guys enjoy what star
trek into darkness is is all of that
plus the substance JJ Abrams continues
to prove that he is one of the best
filmmakers working today I have liked
every single movie that that man has
directed he is extremely talented one of
the great things about the first movie
was that it understood what the original
series was and it got the best things of
that but it also made it new and fresh
this movie also continues to reboot the
franchise in a way even though it's
within the same series this continues to
add new elements to this franchise that
are going to keep it fresh and lively
and I love this film I actually did like
it more than the first one and I love
the first one for sure something this
movie gets even better than the first
one not to dis Eric Bana who I thought
did a good job as Nero in the first film
but Benedict Cumberbatch as the main
villain of this movie dude freakin
fantastic he did such a good job he
really was great
menacing evil his voice his gestures the
way he talked the way he did things just
his entire vibe and aura as a character
was just badass
I loved it he did such a good job in
this movie and the scenes were him and
Kirk and Spock have dialogue together
and they just they just just
summer fun entertainment at its best JJ
Abrams has a really good way of shooting
action he's so intense like I saw with a
friend of mine oddly enough looks a lot
like Zachary Quinto and afterwards he
was like dude I need to go home and sit
down for like 15 minutes because my
heart and everything I'm just I'm so
wired right now like this movie does
that to you it's such a roller coaster
ride Chris Pine gives a great
performance as Kirk in this movie he's
not just a fun likeable guy he's
legitimately great in this movie as is
Zachary Quinto as Spock they both have
such excellent chemistry and the
friendship between Kirk and Spock that
was so famous in the previous movies and
series is so well captured here it's
just so much love to these characters so
much love in this movie and as a fan of
the original films in the original
series there are so many excellent
tributes throughout this movie which I
will not spoil go and enjoy them
yourself because as a fan I guarantee
you are going to be just like whooping
you're just gonna like oh you're just
gonna poop you know how the late great
Roger Ebert would say - thumbs way up
that was that great man's ultimate
praise - a film mine's a lot more
juvenile but it speaks Who I am guys
when you see star trek into darkness you
are going to poop everywhere your dupe
everywhere I swear this movie is awesome
the visual quality of this movie - it
just leaps off the screen of you and I
saw it in 2d which I'm very glad I saw
actually because I'm getting sick of 3d
I didn't go to the advanced screening
this film I saw at the midnight showing
with a crowd that just felt really fun
you know to be able to experience that I
don't want to tell you much anything
else about this movie I just want to
tell you that it took me to emotional
places that most movies don't take you
to this is one of those summer movie
action rides that's so spectacular
that will just take your heart and your
pulse to all different types of levels
and JJ Abrams knows how to touch all
those little strings perfectly and pull
them and get you to experience emotions
that you didn't think you're going to
experience when you watch a Star Trek
movie and it had me surprised at an
almost constant level you just so
saturated with everything being the same
in movies nowadays and to see a big
summer blockbuster that's so smart like
this just good job Abrams you did a
great job with this movie my only issue
with the film is actually maybe like the
first
minutes where it was really fun and
exciting but I didn't really know where
it was going when you watch the rest of
the film you can be like okay I see
where all these little pieces are
important that's really it this is a
fantastic movie I adored it it's one of
the best films I've seen in a while I
loved it even more than the first film
I'm still going to give star trek into
darkness and a I think it's an excellent
movie and as I said I don't really have
any problems with it you just you gotta
reserve the a pluses for those movies
that literally just stop your heart
thanks a lot for watching my review guys
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck my next